[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to playoff action here
at the 2013 US Chess Championship in st.
Louis it's all come down to this
grandmasters Alejandro Ramirez and gada
Kamsky playing off for the US
Championship title $30,000 and to make
their mark on history right the prestige
of the title joining Fischer Reshevsky
yeah sir sorry Juan very Kamsky of
course a very illustrious list of us
just champions of course sada Kamsky the
favorite he's a three-time champion he's
a world championship candidate
I'm extremely experienced at rapid
playoffs he won against your each woman
in one of these before
exactly and Alejandra Ramirez too
surprised to even be here yeah I'm just
happy about the opportunity well I think
he wants to win now
you can smell the blood you can smell
the title and we are also with
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley so yes or
Sara Juan and me are gonna take you
through some of the analysis today of
this exciting game it's going to be game
25 with the five-second increment so a
very quick games yeah as I see it on our
screen we've got the names wrong I guess
they had a drawing of loss just the
player sitting down he gets started
got a camp key sitting in front of the
white pieces on our web cam for Game one
that's right so earlier in an interview
with FM mic/line Alejandro said that he
would prefer to be white first he's
black first there's some advantages to
that as well they do trade colors it's
really important at this kind of level
of chess to get a chance with the white
pieces and such a rapid match absolutely
white defines the character of the game
and let's uh throw to Maurice to give us
a little bit of insight about what it's
like to be the underdog in the situation
well Jen I've never been in this
particular situation playing in a rapid
match for the finals of the US Chess
Championship and neither has Grandmaster
Ramirez before the game he said that he
woke up very early at the jitters he
woke up at seven o'clock he didn't
expect to do that but he had to do some
final preparations
he had his normal breakfast at the
crepes place and he said that with this
money
first of all didn't expect to win the
money he probably buy a house
put it down easy he wasn't even thinking
about it before the tournament and also
he has to change his entire summer plans
because now he's qualified for the World
Cup and he's going to be in Norway in
the summer and he's really excited about
that he said he feels great there's
really no pressure on him he was just
happy to get this fantastic result so
expect him to play freewheeling chess as
he tries to become US champ for the
first time Jenna yes we do have some
moves as we can see here on our web cam
gata Kamsky play d4 now that's
interesting in this tournament mostly
he's been playing e4 in their game in
the tournament he actually played the
main line of array Lopez so we're
switching it up here and unsurprising
because God has so much experience he
can pretty much play anything right he's
always had that universal approach I
think on the web cam I'm seeing the move
c75 where did we go did he start with d4
by the way yes it looked like he did
start with before okay and then we have
Knight f3 and I am NOT getting moves on
my screen at the moment but fortunately
since it's just one game that we're
following we can see very clearly in
this web cam shot what's going on and it
is c5 by Alejandro I noticed by the way
that in that's let's go back Alejandra
is working with chess base and he did a
video on the Banco gambit so after one
d4 Knight f6 gotta play tonight f3 not
wishing to go into a Banco gambit and no
God is thinking well if he plays d5 am I
going to allow Blumenfeld no he's just
played g3 which is backing down actually
from the challenge that blacks second
move c5 made so d4 Knight f6 Knight f3
I'll put this up on our screen
g5 g3 and a little surprise that got a
spent bit of time on that decision three
g3 you would think that he would have
been prepared without the moves in
general seeming to be a little bit rusty
in this tournament and maybe that will
continue throughout this rapid match and
it'll be closer than a lot of fans per
day yeah we have some chess stars in the
audience here Elena Katz from the
Women's Championship is is watching in
the st. Louis chess club we've got
international arbiter Frank Guadalupe
Elliott Lou from chess comm who actually
is going to be giving out a prize for
today's broadcast as well so hashtag us
chest champs bring your questions and
comments and maybe you can win that and
the players have transposed into a kind
of reverse groom felled Catalan and I am
expecting the move c2 c4 after six moves
of play c2 c4 is a standard although I
must say that God I could consider the
move e to e for but strangely enough it
seems to me that neither players has
really prepared for this exact position
that has appeared on the board they're
taking some time for what a very
standard openings as they try to
outguess one another as to what they're
doing well so most people just want to
get into the right flow and a rapid
match because that 5 second increment
does give you a little bit of leeway and
if you play too quickly you can make a
big error I mean it's the big catch-22
goods with rapid play play too fast you
make mistakes and move your right way
too slow you get at the time pressure
and make mistakes later in the game
right know what you're gonna make
mistakes and that's why it's exciting
alright well it's not so easy to
calibrate your play because on one hand
they've been playing classical chess the
whole tournament the other most standard
form of chess is actually five-minute
which is a completely different night 83
was played okay now this is c7 attacking
the pawn on c4 okay that's what that's
what happen is that's what
three okay so he did play your C form of
yes yes and still very early in terms of
opening expectations why the kg Queen c7
I'm not so sure maybe Alejandro was very
happy to introduce to induce night a3
okay but now nights he said oh he just
played d7 d6 okay hmm interesting
gotta wondering what how to steer the
position forwards from here I like the
idea of putting my bishop on b2 I would
probably play the move b2 b3 here if I
were white intending to neutralize the
Bishop on g7 by putting my Bishop on b2
and there's just no tactics here for
black at the moment at the moment
especially after the move d7 d6 by the
way there are certain lines where
sometimes a d7 d5 can be played when
there's a knight on c6 and gada has
taken the approach that I thought he
should he has played the move b2 b3
knowing you you probably enjoyed this
position for white the extra space
exactly the extra space very difficult
for black to generate counter play
Bishop V after eight after b3 a7 a six
just ruling out any future possibilities
of 95 Bishop b2 knight c6 both players
playing pretty solid straightforward
moves Queen d1 d2 and why does the first
player to connect as rooks as we know in
the opening you want to develop your
pieces as quickly as possible
Bishop d7 played by Alejandro and
sometimes a b5 move can occur later in
the game exactly
rook c1 discouraging that putting the
work on the same line as the Queen right
now in this case the knight on a three
quick Knight takes d4 Queen takes d4 has
been played
Bishop 64 94 bit before yeah yes yeah
otherwise is he's already cast its
otherwise not something like 98 would
probably be annoying right trading off
those bishops I think white ones to
avoid trades here because of his face
advantage yes it's it's minuscule but
it's nagging and long-lasting Bishop c6
offering a further trade of pieces and
now here White has a small tactical
operation if he wants he could play the
move Knight b5 let me just put that on
the board Queen d7 Knight c3 so it he
could better position his knight but
then after Bishop takes d5 Bishop defend
Bishop takes g2 King takes G to b5 is a
is a standard equalizing reaction in
these types of positions so that's right
in these maroc C buying type positions
you want to either play for the b5 push
or the d5 push if you can get either
running gracefully usually it means a
comfortable equality for that that's
right
and so here if God is is going to try to
play for an edge and I don't really
think he's got much of one he may go for
an awkward move f2 f3 I don't like that
in terms of playing for afor and he did
play that little tactical operation
Knight b5 and so I am expecting
Alejandro to play Queen d7 certainly a
big blunder would be to capture on b5
after captures this rook on c1 pinning
the Queen White regains his piece with a
huge advantage and that just slashing
Bishop on g2 exactly so that's just a
no-go variation at 1 so Queen d7 is the
expected move now the knight would have
to drop back Bishop takes you to King
takes G to b5 not the only move but
again a very standard move from blacks
point of view to try to just a knight we
do have 95 in the board yes yeah that's
right and we are expecting
Queen d7 not too sure about the clocks
but time definitely not a factor at this
moment as both players have played
pretty quickly after these gaining
jitters where we were surprised they
weren't playing even faster
they've been playing it at a steady pace
since then Queen d7 Knight c3 on the
board
exactly Queen you know you're expecting
b5 is freeing I'm expecting a trade of
on g2 first right okay right so yeah
let's just head back to the on the board
here we also are seeing in our web cam
and Bishop g2 q g2 has occurred and now
85 do you feel like white air it
somewhere or you just think he still has
a little bit of an edge because yeah
well first of all he he does have a
slightly a slight slight slight slight
leave in development so for example
after a move like three acts yeah a
really really really smidgen uh-huh got
it did not play Knight d5 he could have
played Knight d5 before they didn't
played Bishop takes f6 at once okay
Bishop takes f6 was played and now
nightmare oh I see so he's threatening
96 and Knight X takes up six but
something like Queen b7 could save the
day and then we could rescue our Bishop
afterwards right using that pin if Queen
B sevens played and white gets out of
the pin so now I don't know what G 1 or
e 4 let's just put something on the
board so you have time to just backtrack
our Bishop cracks well it's not that
clear Jen because after Ken yeah and c4
there's a sudden threat of rook c7 going
after this pawn on e7 so let's see what
else do we have here after after a so
maybe in a position like this like we
need yeah you could play we could just
capture this pawn but then after takes
takes despite the fact that pawns are
the material is even the
broken pawns on d6 + f6 very pleasant
girl right right so what about Queen b6
Queen b6 careful for ya then you have f3
yeah after Queen e4 check this one f5
like Queen f5 might be uh-huh alejandro
just said okay
double my pawns if you like after the
move Knight d5 he hasn't tried to defend
his Bishop he instead he's contesting
the C file with the move rook on a8 to
ca so here I would expect God to accept
these Delta or force these double pawns
now after a move like well let's just
take this pawn I don't want to have a
split pawn myself and after takes well
sure because you don't want to give up
this d6 pawn unnecessarily where the e2
is in take after Queen B 5 but it does
seem more natural to play a takes b5
because maybe the a file will prove
handy later on as well exactly
and now something along the nature of
say uh-huh
there was no captures on f6 something
like Queen d5 White's got a pull not
anything major got it kept the capture
f6 in reserve for just a moment he may
have had tactical reasons for that he
just captured on b5 we are expecting the
recapture a takes and now I don't know I
would want to eliminate that Bishop I
wouldn't want to allow Oh Queen takes B
father we did play Queen takes b5 with
eyeballing the e2 pawn as you mentioned
that's right so Knight f6 takes on f6
mm-hmm now if white were to play Queen
d6
BM takes e to and if you grab another
pawn I also can grab a - and now b3
tender as well and this just looks dead
yeah
totally equal with all basically all the
pawns coming off the board except for
yeah the castle position very
symmetrical yeah just a wholesale series
of captures and I takes it not what dada
would be going for here with the white
pieces so now though what about just
figuring out a way to defend that pawn
yeah playing III yeah I'd like a III and
White's play is a little bit easier
because what he's intending to do is
simply target this pawn on d6 it's bone
on f6 isn't going to be a major target
for white black is going to play f6f-5
when necessary so this pawn is the akhil
achilles heel at the moment in blacks
position hard not to like white let's
find out what a grandmaster moy is
actually think for the position so far
well Jen I've been checking with the
computer and it thinks that black is a
little worse but not that much
Chomsky's been playing very simply not
necessarily the most accurate moves as
you can imagine in this very quick time
control so it looks as though there's a
slight edge for white but very tenable
we know in queen and double rook endings
usually even an extra pawn sometimes may
not be enough if it's not past and right
now it looks like Ramirez is holding his
own back to you Jenny yes that being
said I think Alejandro's position in the
classical tournament was even more
comfortable with black if I recall
correctly that was a Rory Lopez where he
seemed to get a pretty comfortable
position out of the opening
yeah but later in the game Dada was
really kicking himself because as he
that's said he came back and he said he
thought he just had a winning position
and then bang Bishop h3 appeared on the
board that's right so he did actually
yeah we probably Alejandro got a decent
opening but then somehow got it ended up
with an endgame edge anyway so yeah
perhaps well in this position one of the
things that Alejandro absolutely cannot
afford to do is he cannot afford to go
pass it putting his rook on d8 or
conversely putting his rook on e8 and e
six would in my opinion constitute
passive play he has to play rook c8 in
my opinion in this position go for
counter play against the a pawn for
instance so if I say if rook do you want
I'm thinking he should play moves like
Queen f3 and if you went upon you gotta
go active in this position just give up
that pawn on d6 and go after the pawn on
f2 or a2 if indeed it did seem like he's
put his rook to c8 and then after rook
to d1 he wanted to play Queen to c2 so
instead of your Queen f3 okay so how
Andra is willing to sacrifice a pawn and
go into an ending that he can think he
thinks he can draw rook and 4 versus
rook and 3 that's right so he thinks
that after Queen takes you to rook see
to work takes d6 yes rook takes a 2
after-work takes f6 correct he believes
that he can hold it all in this position
but you know certainly gotta Kamsky is
gonna try yes and gotta try what is a 2
a 4 and again I don't think black should
go passive and he did go pass it I was
just about to say I don't think he
should go passive what you wanted Rafi
to or something precisely I think he
should have just continued his idea of
keeping his rook as active as possible
cuz he didn't like I guess maybe you
didn't like work these six and taking on
a sex though or are you gonna do with it
with the a pawn looking for with the
Brooklyn 4 versus working for with the a
pond that's really drawn with the b-pawn
some chances but not with the a pond
what he did do
pardon me was play rook c6 right he did
go passive after a four loops army after
a four rook c6 if you can just help me
get to the position what happened after
rook c6 maybe we'll go to Maurice and
Maurice could fill us in on some moves
as I was looking at something else
actually after rook to d4 he played King
to f8
did did black and then come ski
immediately played rook to be for the
computer things this is really close
practically nothing for white but we
know calm skis technique in the endgame
is incredible I remember him as a 16 17
year old studying hours and hours a day
the end game that's where the difference
is at the highest level so I think even
though the computer likes blacks chances
here that Chomsky is in his element
right now we've got to give the edge to
him that's right computers don't always
assess well the practical chances like
yesterday Timur garea with his better
centralised King and no his is a
slightly superior chances that we kept
getting a 0-0 0 score but actually it
was hard for Conrad to figure out how to
hold the balance that's right and so
sometimes you got to be a little
skeptical especially in the end games
because computer is blessed sometimes
with those there was an ala mob
databases are able to super humanize
some of the yeah and game deck made well
in this position I don't really see how
white could really make black suffer too
much as long as black keeps an active
rook gets in the moves f5 and maybe h5
there's no breakthrough on the Queen
side and the problem is if we grab that
a pawn you'll just be able to get behind
you'll continue to put pressure on our
beep on great and just be able to get
behind the pond and there's just no way
for white to really progress here
exactly
alejandro after King e6 has played the
move rook c2 by the way so we're in this
position at the moment and instead of
rook c5 he played rook c2 I like this
I've always said you know like in rook
endings the best way to defend the rook
endings funnily enough just to keep as
your rook as active as possible and as
we say in the ending rooks belong behind
passed pawns and it's true for both
players that's right and gata Kamsky
playing a very grand
remove here g4r I've seen you for so
much of this sort of and usually in the
metal game but here in the end game I'm
just trying to gain a little bit of
space and discourage the two moves that
you thought would really solidify blacks
position that age five in that f5 mode
exactly I wanted to get an f5 a little
bit earlier than this so with this move
g4 White's advantage which is small just
increased a fraction a very practical
advantage in this type of rapid game Oh
maybe tiny in a classical time control
where Alejandro has all the time in the
world to you know figure out how to hold
in a rapid game really anything can
happen here yes still better for y
winning is very very unlikely but
definitely some pull for the first
player and got a well I mean like we say
his greatest attribute is his
extraordinary technical skill and here
he's got something that he can chew on
like a dog in his boat so nor some more
grandmasters and stars literally biting
their nails as they watch this game
Grandmaster Ben Feingold the st. Louis
local and talked to Barbara haami on who
placed third and the Women's Champion
track very good very good enjoying the
action I still don't see too much maybe
Maurice has an insight Maurice
yes he has the computer agrees and I was
desperate to see this move f5 show up on
the board or h5 I've been ground down by
the likes of you yes in these kind of
end games where you didn't let you
didn't get you allowed this move g4 to
happen and the black king side gets
squeezed you can't really push any pawns
because you're gonna end up with a bad
pawn structure so the computer itself
recognized this and said f5 was
definitely better and by allowing g4
black has allowed white to have a little
bit tinier edge and you know calm skis
feeling better and probably Ramirez is
thinking about this as well hmm maybe I
shouldn't have let that move happen so
let's see what how he handles himself
from now on back to you guys
yeah a nice point there you sometimes
you start kicking yourself you know for
saying well why did I allow him that why
do I allow on that and it starts to
creep up on your own self-confidence why
is this such an important Grandmaster
move to play 85 to prevent g4 because
for those of us viewing at home g4 just
looks like an everyday move what's the
big deal
yeah the big deal actually has to do
with these these double pawns the move
g4 freezes oh he has played
h5 okay well that's definitely not
something that g4 is usually concerned
about because that creates another
weakness which certainly makes way more
fun for white that's right that that's
another weakness and that pawn over on
this side of the board
oh boy so you don't like that move h5 o
not like h5 so so g4 you were just
explaining that it was giving white a
lot more space and it was preventing
black from really doing much anything
and that can sometimes become a problem
because the point does not say a pawn at
some point a lot of times blacks drawing
chances revolve around getting active on
the Kings side while the White King
moves over that's right that's right and
now that this bonus is weak over here on
h5 it makes ideas like Ruby six six
which was played a pardon me f5 was a
5-liter member g6 and respond six no
you're forced to go behind Brooke B 2
will be 2 on the board and now the idea
is that after we gotta find it with King
after a knee right
and suddenly White's advantage is
starting to pick up in my view because
there's even ideas of King of foreign
King King g5 I'm aware of look F 2 is in
the position currently but King of four
maybe he played King F 3 to stop a
potential f4 idea I wonder if that would
might have been something also there's a
nice prophylactic move making sure that
f4 doesn't come in too
for black getting rid of his double pawn
perhaps so now one of the problems
because of this pawn sitting out here on
h5 is a future variation like rook a six
rook b3 rook e8 rook h6 white could in a
near-future
trade the a pawn for the H pawn and then
he'll still have a passed pawn that'll
likely be a draw but this is also one
idea of how white could transfer one
advantage to another also by pushing
this pawn maybe to the a7 square that
would force black into King that's right
right and then ultimately to G to
perhaps all the way to g7 to stop your
work HHH five idea exactly so still good
play here for gada Kamsky in this first
game at the playoffs
excellent practical chances and as the
Russian grandmasters often like to say
playing for two results Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley what are your thoughts
all rook endings are drawn and it
doesn't mean that all working is a drone
obviously but the fact is Brooke endings
are extremely technical they stay within
bounds
you can often give up a pawn and have an
active rook and still draw the game and
that is what Ramirez is doing right now
he's saying super active in this
position look at his dominant King in
the middle of the board if he were to be
passive got a consequence just March up
but in this situation staying very
active and preventing cops key from
making any obvious progress which is why
you see the super technician Russian
Grandmaster here thinking how do I do
this those black pawns look awful
but activity Trump's today sometimes
still a slight edge for white though
according to the computer we got some
great tweets coming in here and a side
us chest champs I really like this one
this one's from Realtor Derrick ass he
says I couldn't make a trip down to the
Chess Club is classic senator st. Louis
for the US chest champs but I'm pulling
for Ramirez if you need help buying home
I'll gladly help
closing are always closing great great
yeah beware if you say anything publicly
about trying to buy a home you will get
tweets emails etc any financial advisors
out there and we have some gingy fan who
asks there's a rapid format pay for the
youth nope I don't think so
I think the rapid format favors the
excellent experience you know you can
play multiple openings his strategic
sense is it allows them to play quickly
nerves so I think that the rapid format
actually favors gata Kamsky in this in
this instance but oh maybe we do would
you disagree with that do you think that
goddess chances would be even higher in
a classical format do you think it's
about the same I think it's about the
same but I agree with you that
experience is huge just the whole
stressed nervous factors when you've
never been there before
it's tough Maurice has an insight
Maurice well my thought is that yes God
is favored here for sure come on the
guy's been a world championship
candidate but Ramirez
you know tournaments are often about
performance how you're performing right
now Ramirez has been playing wonderful
chess he surprised got her early in the
tournament he shocked him with this move
Bishop to h3 yesterday he played a
brilliant game against Christensen so I
think he's informed and look at him and
I said leaning back relaxed he knows
that this position is within bounds of
drawing even though calm ski might be
the technician but he right now is sort
of the running favorite everybody's
rooting for him got it knows that as
well and doesn't care too much but still
he's very confident very calm and maybe
youth won't necessarily triumph but
sometimes confidence plays a big role
and the capture has been made on a six
rook the rook takes one be three and our
K doesn't play that is true we do have a
lot of alejandro fans out there he is a
fun guy likes to hang out in between in
between the games and is uh Jorge
somewhere has been told me there's no
word for nerd and Spanish really
probably doesn't exist
females like to enjoy the chest try the
chest plane traveling lifestyle in
addition to our playing some great games
and we do have the apron here the
players have followed our main line of
analysis and have actually simply caught
up with us for the moment so the big
deal from whites point of view is he
wants to set up the small tactical
operation of pushing his pawn to a7 so
that he could move his rook to e8 with a
discover check-in time to promote the
pawn f4 by Alejandro Ramirez mmm earlier
I think maybe waking f3 to prevent that
I guess the line that Alejandro has
looked at as a seven King f5 so a seven
of course threatens rook e8 Shaq
followed by Queen so the king has to
guard itself from the check by by
placing itself in front of a pawn and we
do have this position on the board and
King e - and this was a nice decision in
my view by Ramirez he managed to get
this position and trade off his doubled
F pawns which were a conservative world
weakness and he's just played the move
Fe 3 Fe 3 and I think that operation by
Ramirez has secured him the draw I have
to just be absolutely sure that it's not
a hundred percent but yeah I think the
bishop yeah it was a nice time we move
there well that's another example of the
computer evaluation sometimes being a
little off actually computer evaluation
shot up for white but maybe from a
practical point of view the move f4
actually helps black on who's drawing
mission we do have a very elite player
grandmaster Hiro Nakamura still the US
Champion by the way oh yes I'm Dean Ian
wanted to let everyone know that not
everyone is rooting for Ramirez in fact
he expects a guy at Kemps need to win
this match okay well thank Carl got a
respect his
and he knows his Olympic member very
well got a camp ski so there we go
and a Grand Master Maurice Ashley
responds to that well I think there's a
difference between rooting for someone
and expecting them to win
you might root for Ramirez and still
think that come skis gonna win the match
gray says there's that very big
difference of course there might be
something between Ramirez and Nakamura
that I don't know about but certainly
calm ski remains the prohibitive
favorite to win but still people love it
on the dog pure and simple folks loving
and the dog would love to see a new
champion emerge for the very first time
that's right we do love underdogs in
America all right I heard that it's the
culture is like a bit different in a lot
of other countries and that it's not
really consider it adds fun to root for
underdogs yes it's a kind of American
mentality that we see in movies sports
right and we do have moves I I now think
that the position is in fact that drawn
with proper play by black and Ramirez
played rook-a for King d3 King ff6 and I
think that this is the right idea for
black after King c3 to put the king
simply on e7 guarding the D pawn and
whenever white tries to bring his king
to the b6 square the rooks gonna drop
back onto the first rank and keep giving
checks so that Harry the white king and
make a draw by repetition this is the
drawing technique that I visualize for
Ramirez now I got a request to show some
checkmates unfortunately since we don't
have mates in this position I'll do the
second best thing and show a blunder
what about if black moves his f1 in this
position okay after for example let's
just say let me go back wait well yeah
okay we get some position like this this
would be the blunder you're referring to
gen that the rook of move and skewer the
black rook from the side right and this
is kind of a staple of end game theory
when the pawns are missing from the
board and don't shield the king
sometimes
this can spell the end for that position
for black even though his rook is well
placed and behind the pond exactly and I
think we do have a number of moves h4 h3
has been played King to b3 oops
King to e7 pardon me King to b3 rook to
a1 came to c4 by gotta rook drop back
just stopping the King momentarily from
crossing the Rubicon of the half the
board into blacks camp King has gone to
be fine and this was why I thought that
the King on e7 was so vitally important
checks to the white king another
important note for those of us who don't
get into a lot of working games he it's
crucial that black keeps checking the
King especially when the King gets up to
b6 is at that point the rook would be
released in white we just win easily
exactly so I'm expecting rook to c5
check just to force the white king
backwards which in fact has happened
King efore played and quickly behind the
a ponts of that there was no rook and
Queen queening by white king f4 has been
played now I know I don't want to lose
the H pawn so I would think that a move
like rook who the computer sure didn't
like that one rook a5 would allow the
King to jump to g5 so here I guess the
simplest is simply King f6 to keep the
White King from making any progress on
the King side well it doesn't look like
both players have over 10 minutes oh no
meter time pressure here and one little
clarification from Grandmaster Nakamura
he just doesn't he doesn't just expect
cam to get a win he is also rooting for
him ah both okay well you know I mean I
I Olympic teammates of course I make
sense they've had a lot of experience
playing on teams together and I'm sure
built a friendship and also just working
in relationship really they're
colleagues an understanding and a a
shout out again to Jakara for his
wonderful victory over the world
champion Viswanath on a non absent in
the norway chess event that was
outstanding and vichy does not lose that
many games per year and that victory
with the black pieces is a double double
victory for Hikaru very first victory
and not his last against anon that's my
bold prediction and Grandmaster Horace
actually has another comment
adding to that not only his victory
against unknown but his draw against
Carlsen as well shows that he knows how
to play chess at the very highest level
I would add that in this position I'm
I'm reminded of the position from
yesterday that Garay have beat halt in
where the position was simply drawn it
was just like just make a few moves and
it's a draw but the higher rated player
kept probing and probing and probing and
letting the game continue and continue
just to see if the lower rated player
would be able to keep up the technique
and in the end under time pressure
Holt ended up blundering and losing the
game and we were all just so depressed
for him I mean he just looked like
someone totally beaten after playing
such a wonderful tournament at slouching
at the board at the end so Ramirez will
have to be careful here he knows he has
this draw this is definitely equal but
don't get into time pressure against a
high rated player a technician like calm
ski will grind you down back to you guys
I absolutely agree and shout out to
Conrad Holt who did play a fantastic
tournament and the one consolation for
me is it was it was heartbreaking to see
him lose that game but he did win the
World Cup spot yeah I mean he's got to
be proud about that it was a few
thousand dollar financial swing we're
losing the game but the World Cup spot
worth more than that and of course just
a fantastic result by the youngster Jen
I forgot to ask you that at the opening
of the show do we have a breakdown as to
who did in fact take the five qualifying
spots that's right that's ownership
ramirez garea
and hole halt yes as I just mentioned
and then Larry Kristensen was the five
pointer
one on tiebreak I so those five
fantastic five indeed yes I have a
fantastic five
the Magnificent five and a four youth
and we've got veteran in there and it'll
be great to root for that man and in
fact we do also have of course Kai
Donovan Shambhala who qualified from the
Continental so that's seven and then he
Carl and gata Kamsky who are qualifying
by rating so we're gonna have at least
nine I understand it properly and
Maurice for more highlights guys the
computer say there's only one move right
now it's King of six he has to find it
or else he's going down this is
important that he doesn't lose material
he must play King f6 this is critical to
not let that white King jump into the
game and he has found believe it so he's
still fine dwell within bounds excellent
nurse Ramirez he's been playing rather
quickly in this in the same game
actually but then he really took his
time on this move like was key yeah I
spent two or three minutes on this move
realizing that and and and there was
that stoic nurse of gotta camps he gotta
I think fully understood that King f6
was the only move to save the game and
when he saw the move King f6 it was like
expected it never any doubts but
inwardly I'm sure he felt damn okay okay
for Jack King h5 k f5 on the board all
right we're okay have to protect the
pawn god it keeps his king nearby and
king f5 has been played and no this is
the problem for gotta
how does he improve his position how
about efore check well I better not play
rook takes e4 working takes e4 teen
takes e4 work the 8th check that's the
stood that's the trick ease that white
is looking for so he can promote on the
next move and if I play rook takes e4
similar thought I just moved my rook
from behind the pawn and I'm promoting
next so that's why it's so important to
just keep that would be high in the past
pawn and it's a it's a mixed blessing to
have the pawn on a seven on one hand it
creates tactics but on the other you
Tai's way down so he has no flexibility
here you either gotta find something or
there's nothing and so instead as you
point out just moving the King back to
f6 cuz now when you do take on h4 I can
take with check and then move on back
behind the pond where their work belongs
psi so you Maurice more highlights after
efore check the computer saying king f4
confidently surging forward is even
better than King f6 and after you lose
the pawn on h4 King takes h4 then rook
a3 and white is actually in some sort of
zugzwang unable to make any moves
whatsoever without losing a pawn so King
h5 being impossible because of rook
takes h3 mate so why would actually have
to give away the a pawn and then the e
pawn and the game would quickly end up
in a draw Peter out so key for King m4
is and the King takes h4 is just a draw
after work a3 Wow impressive nerves here
by grandmaster Ramirez who is just
defending well in a worse position
against gata Kamsky absolutely fantastic
and we have got some more stars in the
audience co-founder of the st. Louis
chess club here Jamie Cynthia I see
Genie big fan and around there just
enjoying the playoff action and I right
now we're having fun I mean we're free
loosie loosie goosie but i tell you when
you go up there and you're in that
spectator audience you can feel the
nerves of the players and the tension
increasing with each and every move it's
not a lot of fun being at the board but
you really get the idea of the emotion
that is taking place it is very very
stressful I'm glad I'm down here with
you Jen it's fun watching down here but
you're right they be Eric completely
thick with tension and a lot of fun to
watch rapid and blitz games in person so
I should all come down to st. Louis just
go for the next major event absolutely
okay so what could God a Kamsky possibly
do to force some Mook
he has played the movie for
check I was about to look at a position
with after King h6 and I thought that
was just gonna lead to a dead end
he has played efore check and I'm like
the human move
pardon me unlike the computer move King
f4 I thought the human move was King f6
Ramirez played King f6 in an instant and
we do have King takes h4 and instead of
capturing this pawn with a check Ramirez
went for d5 interesting d5 Thank You g3
looks like it was played King g3 and I'm
so I absolutely do assume that ramirez's
idea is to capture this pawn with the
pawn not with the rook which would lose
and he has in fact done that and I like
what Ramirez has done here because this
is absolutely easy now as well king f4
has been played and Maurice has
highlights well I just wanted to say yes
isn't this a book draw even if I take
away two black pawns from the board
that's right even without the pawns you
can't win this position the King stays
on g7 this is well known you need at
least an F pawn for white to win the
position so marinus can even play III
check now donate all the pawns leave his
King right on g7 and there is absolutely
no way he can lose this position this
game should end in a draw
that's right Maurice I the King on g7
avoids all those scores and checks that
we were looking at earlier so it's kind
of counterintuitive in this endgame
because normally you want your team to
be active in the endgame but here you
want to put it far away so that white
doesn't have any tricks that's right and
just as you said Maurice and Jan even
without these two pawns on the board the
positions a draw with the two pawns on
the board I think have to move like f5
the players would agree to a draw right
away the best that Y could do is capture
this pawn and after e3 the rook would
have to give up its protection of the a7
pawn and then it's just dead dead dead
so I don't know what the computer is
thinking but I'm thinking the players
about to agree to a draw
after the move f7 f5 but a nice test for
the young ramirez which he passed with
flying colors
in this the first game but camp ski is
happy that he at least was given a
chance to test this technique a little
bit yeah one way but definitely this is
great it's another good end game lesson
for the viewers at home right so
absolutely if you even if you put it on
the board the f5 and then let's just
like play take chess with our pawns to
show to show maurices point it's f5 King
takes no you know let's say we play work
let's say we just play work a3 or
something just for fun oh I see I see
just to point out yeah oh oh you want to
take a look ensure okay instead of the
move f5 as I had recommended King h7 h5
King g7 one last-gasp attempt by Kamsky
he played the move h6 check you can't
take because we've seen this time and
time again the rook would come with
check and a8 would win the game for for
white but now King h7 and King III and
I'm expecting f5 and I don't see any
reason why God is looking at the clock
he's ready to read or draw Maurice
comment I mean it's almost alaria I got
a nose it's a dead draw he wants to say
yeah okay draw but the guy's not just
proving it if all Ramirez has to do is
display rook a one even and and just
look at the position he knows it's a
draw I'll give you both my opponents on
purpose mm-hmm okay one take play f5 and
you'll say oh okay you know what the
deal is
oh but God is wondering what why doesn't
he show it right there's no reason for
Ramirez to be thinking right now just
force the action and God it would just
immediately take the draw
well maybe thinking for next round and
f5 has been played and this cutesy
little move rook a6 I don't understand
why he didn't play rook a5 just keeping
this pawn protected
but rook a6 was ramirez's decision and
after King takes f5 III this is how we
get to a dead wrong position and it has
been agreed fantastic performance by
Ramirez a big test in Game one of these
playoffs
he drew comfortably or a little
uncomfortably but still a draw Maurice
your insight he drew with ease in my
opinion yeah that just showed real
Grandmaster technique Tomsky tried for a
little something here and there but he
played some really nice moves I like his
idea of f4 when he got rid of his double
pawns we also actually didn't even
expect him to go into this position when
he played h5 remember we thought right
that really dropped his ability to
defend by a lot but he said no these
pawns are fine don't worry about it you
got a garbage a pawn you're not gonna be
able to do anything with any shelter I
will always draw this position maybe
cops keep pushing that apron a little
too quickly but still I didn't see how
to make progress and as I said
performance is but sometimes more
important than rating how you're
performing right now his performance
rating in fact is the highest of the
entire event even better than calm skis
his performance showing that he's
playing at an elite level and now he's
got white with everything to play for he
wins it he's the US Champion fantastic
gen right that's hard to call gata
Kamsky the big favorite now because he
has to play with the black pieces I'd
I'd say it's pretty even chances at this
point what do you think I thought that
Gado was a two-to-one favorite going
into the match this makes the situation
a little bit more like only a 55% favors
okay so you still think he's a slight
favor because if the game is drawing you
like his chances in the army gotta yeah
and the weirdest thing about goddess
play in this tournament which has not
impressed he's not playing a world
championship caliber that we know he's
capable of he's actually playing better
with the black pieces you'll recall his
game against cheval off earlier in the
tournament which might have been got his
best game at the tournament where he
played great and won it with the black
pieces so
we've got everything to play for and
we're gonna be coming back for the
second playoff game we're gonna take a
couple of tweets okay from the hashtag
us chest champs we and we like encourage
you to send more as we great website for
this playoff and we got a couple
comments about the word nerd in Spanish
poker addict that missed the flop says
that the word for nerd in Spanish is
nerdy Oh doh sounds like Spanglish to me
mm-hmm we got another one
Oliver Cashman Brown who says that
apparently the Spanish in Spanish
language word for a nerd is Empoleon
okay okay so you gotta be careful we say
on the broadcast cuz people will look it
up next next task for you guys to study
this ringing him in the break and as we
had to break it we got one more comment
from Grandmaster Ashley yes Jen I just
wanted to point out that God himself
said that he has not been playing well
with the white pieces that he's been
playing much better with the black
pieces that is kind of interesting for
the moment because let's say he only
draws with black right now and doesn't
win what's gonna happen in the
Armageddon game if Ramirez gets black
he's shown that he can draw a God will
have to go for the win with white how
they gonna bid it's gonna be really
interesting but we'll save that until
the if and when it comes up guys all
right and we are going to be back in
just a few minutes for the second game
of this playoff match between Ramirez
and Kamsky to determine the US Chess
Champion and in this game of course
Ramirez is going to be able to take a
shot with the white pieces I can't wait
to see what's gonna happen we'll be
right back with more
[Music]
yeah we should come back they're gonna
have camera we can come back five
minutes and chat
you
you
you
you
[Music]
we're gonna dismiss at the beginning of
the game exactly
all right welcome back to 2013 us chess
championship playoff we've got a very
low PES in this game we were kind of
expecting actually for the Royal up has
to occur lasting exactly and sorry we
got a little late on the start we were
working on getting the board all set up
nicely we've got a royal Lopez I'm
trying to figure out the position
castles Bishop e7 I believe rook e1 b5
got a Kamsky black Bishop e3 Castle anti
Marshall which we were discussing in
some of the other games right so yeah we
saw in another game in this tournament
John Bryant just freezingly took this
pawn and won a nice game you mentioned
that you prefer the anti Marshall system
h3 over the a for anti Marshall exactly
it's a it's a choice but a 2 a 4 in this
particular case maybe to get God out of
his preparation that he'd hoped maybe to
play the Marshall gambit to begin with
and then at the same time maybe was
expecting h3 God has played obviously
the move a4 sets up the threat of a
takes b5 gada handles that threat with
Bishop b7 in order to defend the rook on
a 8 and now the key moment for Ramirez
does he want to play he has played d3 I
was about to say does he want to keep
the game closed with d3 which he chose
to do and d7 d6 quickly by gada Kamsky
in this line of play I'm used to seeing
the move Knight c3 with the idea of
slipping the night either to e2 and g3
or in some cases jumping to the square
d5
so Knight c3 is my primary move here let
me just see what else h2 h3 usual move
that we do see in the Rui Lopez in this
particular position Queen d7 played very
quickly the idea behind Queen d7 this
night is actually misplaced on the
square see six black would like to play
the move c7 c5 the move Queen d7 sets up
a maneuver of night dat six to c5 and
perhaps a lot of in a lot of times in
this opening you try to play Knight a5
and c5 but it's a perhaps a bit
difficult to do that now well okay so
from whites point of view suppose white
plays the move Knight c3 directly Knight
a5 in this case just don't fall for one
terrible possibility of don't you dare
think of capturing that pawn on a4 oh no
because the bishop takes a seven and
Knight c3 was played but we can just
play c5 at that moment yes continue to
try to get our stake in the center
exactly so Knight c3 was played
threatening a double capture on b5 after
trade of rooks but here I if I were
black I would probably up for the move
knight c6 to d8 keeping the b5 palm
protected and I just think the knight is
better placed on the e6 square then on
the a5 square gotcha
yeah it's true we do gain that tempo
against the bishop but you don't think
that's worth as much in this close
position right exactly I'm just thinking
that and let's see God my god oh my god
it makes a fool of me Knight a5 was
goddess choice well one thing with the
95 is there are some variations where
you get a chance to play B 4 and B 3 and
sacrifice upon right and to retain it
later and B 4 has been played and we're
up to date not so clear on the clocks
but it looks like they're pretty well
balanced and uh Alejandro here played 19
instead of your move 92 right now 95 all
right well this capture if you take on
d5 and and black pardon me if white
makes a mistake of capturing with the
pond then now III doesn't yeah looks
really good yeah the pond that we get is
bigger than the pond that you get
precisely so so we got to go back after
Knight takes d5 it's almost a certainty
that Bishop takes d5 has to be played
and now black has a interesting up in he
has played Knight takes d5 Bishop takes
d5 automatically played has easily
predicted now there's Bishop on b7
I'm just a little curious a lot of
options here 6 you can play Bishop takes
Bishop what would you lean towards
exactly it's not an easy choice because
quite frankly it's hard to make a
judgment as to which Bishop stands
better for example c7 c6 Bishop jumps
back c5 can you say that this bishop
which looks pretty good is better than
this Bishop I'm not a hundred percent
sure especially because at some point we
might be able to arrange that d5 push
which were all definitely neutralized
your Bishop on a2 and on the other hand
opening up the C file from blacks point
of view is pretty attractive because
after takes takes Knight takes and no he
did play the other variation he played
c6 Bishop a true c5 there might be a
slight inclination for gotta to try to
keep pieces on the board here if he
thinks that otherwise the situation is
balanced so um he chose this line and I
think that we have another balanced
position on our hands I think that God
it can be relatively pleased with the
outcome of the opening although white
still seems to have a pleasantry Lopez
type position and Alejandro did play is
c3 right on the other hand huh if I were
black I would be a little bit a tad
concerned about this Knight
sitting out here on this wayward square
a five that here's one potential idea
how's this for a pawn sacrifice if black
were to make this pawn sacrifice if you
take with a pawn this Bishop isn't that
happy and after it moves like rook c8
attempting to win this pawn back that
creates a very intriguing position of
the board I like the material but I'm
not 100% oh pardon me there's a ninety
five shot I have I definitely don't want
to allow a ninety five shot so don't
take it in that case but then maybe the
idea is to play King to h8 to release
the F pawn take a look and see what a
grandmaster Maurice Ashley thinks about
the outcome of this opening so far the
position definitely is equal nothing
really special for white or black the
question is does that favor someone I
mean certainly Kamsky wants to have an
equal position that he coming out with
the black pieces but then again he knows
the further this goes the more random
the elements are going to become and
especially in that Armageddon game that
will be looming right at the end of this
so certainly looks like a very tepid
opening this is the kind of position if
they if you saw this at a 2700 level
you'd be thinking this is gonna be a
draw for sure by the way before the game
Tomsky was in his deep meditation mode
at the board for several minutes while
Ramirez walked around casually Chomsky
stated the board seemingly clearing his
mind for the battle ahead Jenny gasps I
was about to say from what Maurice was
just saying we were watching the webcam
I saw very very stoic got gata Kamsky
the god Kamsky i know so very well he
wasn't revealing anything earlier in the
tournament we saw gotta oftentimes
clutching his head and shaking it very
very unusual for gotta normally we see
him this clear and we do have a move by
that's right I mean God accounts he did
win his first four games
and then went on to draw his final five
and it seemed like ever since he was at
Bishop h3 shot he had been shaking his
head but today back to his professional
sense
Daniel wrench from chess comm says that
it looks like it looks as though that
Ramirez is seeming body language poised
to win this championship and he asked me
what the divide is on sight
well the vibe is on sight is a lot of
tension and a lot of fans for both
players but I can't really say one way
or the other it does seem like last game
Ramirez seemed very proud of himself and
as he should be to draw so comfortably
with the black pieces true Maurice has
some highlights first Maurice the last
move by Kamsky and Ramirez are both
frowned on by the computer bishop to see
six seemingly threatened this pawn on a4
but in fact wasn't really a threat
because if the pawn were taking that
discovered attack was still possible as
you mentioned before yes so the computer
really liked after this move Bishop to
c6 taking on b4 taking back and then d4
just ignoring the pawn on his last game
against Larry Christensen where he gave
up his a pawn for a fantastic play or
Ramirez missed this opportunity to just
go for it in the middle of the board
after Bishop c6 and instead he played
the move after Bishop c6 Bishop d5 which
the computer now says is better for
black the computer likes Bishop takes
pawn takes a cup of pawn takes here a
couple of trades and then a rook to b8
and it says black is a little bit better
here so Ramirez missed a big opportunity
to bust open the center of the board
guys interesting so evaluating it this
is slightly better for black just
because black controlling the only open
filed the board that's right right and
that often happens in the were Lopes
that black actually had a superior
development a lot of cases White's
play is more luxurious geared towards a
closed position so when things open up
once in a while it's black who's really
on top in the right indeed indeed and
this move Bishop d5 that is a very very
strange move you don't really want to
voluntarily accept those double pawns
and as Maurice pointing out very
experienced Grandmaster got a camp ski
is used to playing both sides of the
these lines in the rural a post although
he just made a slip in oh no he has
captured on c3 I thought I saw rook b8
without the capture he did and he did
follow the computer suggestion which is
a very straightforward idea clearly this
night on a5 you don't want it tagged on
the edge of the board for that but if
this Knight can code slip to b3 and even
in some cases be supported by the move
c5 c4
I have a slight bias for blacks position
c4 was played by Ramirez so there is
this opportunity for Knight v3 which I
think you should take advantage of that
Knight is not doing anything otherwise
on the a Phi Square attacking the rook
the rook has to keep the site of the
pawn on a4 and how about a move like
rook before not necessarily just jumping
for joy and capturing this bishop at
once and then quickly doubling on the
open B file I'm beginning to like God
has positioned more and more and we
spoke about this earlier that he's
actually been playing better with black
in this event and it's beginning to show
here as God it works on establishing a
Queen side initiative that's right and
white on the other hand no real play
pretty passive pieces I mean nothing has
passed the fourth-ranked so except for
this pawn on d5 but all of whites piece
is quite passive blacks looking really
good here I don't know if maurice has a
more insights here but this position i
think favors black yes i got to agree
with you Black is for choice here
Ramirez especially allowing this trade
on d5 that freed blacks F pawn that I
didn't really like at all now black has
nowhere to be concerned in the entire
position what is White's supposed to do
here why it has no positive plan at all
this is not the kind of position you
want to play against one of the world's
elite players come ski knows he's better
now and it's just a question of playing
just the right moves
I like black that's right it's just so
difficult to come up with active plans
for right here can't really play in the
center because the d4 push traditionally
an active plan in the rival PES can't
really play on the kingside just no real
pushes to me correctly you're kind of
confined to anticipating blacks threats
and hoping to neutralize on and gada has
played the anticipated night b3 after
all that night on a5 was off the edge of
the board now it leaps into the battle
night b3 attacking the rook played b1 it
looks like he played okay rook b1 yeah
so because probably if Queen takes a 492
would be a strong response okay so that
point is still not actually on pre
because of 92 and as you mentioned this
pin oops that would not be good
all right so rook e1 was played and that
provoked God had to capture this bishop
on the surface it appears that this
bishop is weak actually it passive due
to these three pawns actually that's not
the case this bishop when as maurice
mentioned after you play f5 and put your
bishop on f6 that could be a very strong
bishop indeed now Queen takes c1 was
captured so they said now the sacrifice
is real Knight if you take on a4
immediately or work a 1 should be
sufficient and maybe not are you going
after but you're right you do have ok 3
3 but then you can maybe or I was
thinking you could also perhaps just
protect the protecta pawn after ok 3
which you couldn't have done earlier
right but here you do you do have just
Queen to b6 backing it up although I
could set up a enough enough major
pieces I think on that pawn and it's
gonna be hard for you to continue to
defend
right after Queen to a-1 if you play
Burke a8 and I play Queen a2 or worried
look and then Queen a2 you're probably
your favorite to win the pawn DAC it
looks like are you so sure I've got this
nifty little Bishop to d8 to protect
that pawn when I need to and this Knight
is a long way from capturing that pawn
if you don't capture the a pawn it stays
on the board for awhile let's go back to
the game position just to see the
situation at hand
got a camps key reaching for and grab
has grabbed the pawn this could be it I
mean we're gonna really see whether or
not we're memorizing this compensation
is sufficient here and if it's not got a
Kempster you could very well win this
game and working one was played
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley what do you
think about this pawn grab well I like
the pawn but the computer thinks it's
equal the computer is already saying
white has sufficient play here that this
pawn is going nowhere fast
and maybe calm ski have played a little
bit too quickly grabbing the pawn
instead should have played the move look
to be for cementing his rook on that be
for square in a passed pawn on before
because the trade was practically forced
would have been better than this choice
it thinks that white is firmly in the
game but still Ramirez is going to have
to find all those moves in order to
prove that he has compensation all right
and we do have work a three on the board
and now god it's got to decide where he
wants to put that Queen we're predicting
that he'll hold back track with the
Queen and try to possibly defend the a
pawn but if if Ramirez can't round it up
black of course would be much better so
that's what we're predicting at this
point now probe you guys listening on at
home wondering what's gonna happen if
this game is a draw we are gonna have
more playoff action we're gonna have
what we call an Armageddon game that's a
deathmatch game but it's not gonna be
blitz it's also gonna be rapid in an
Armageddon game black gets drawn so for
the rapid game to be fair white tends to
have a lot more time right now normally
they have the five minutes verse three
minutes
splits game instead in the rapid game
the two players bid for how much
they're willing to take to sacrifice to
get those draw odds and the black piece
is so by the way God a did back up with
us Queen he played Queen b7 retreating
to protect the pawn on 86 very quickly
Queen a1 was seen and we we had checked
a line that went rook a8 rook be one
Queen a7 protecting the pawn and hoping
to set up for a five but then I think
this move rook b3 threatening to come
down to b7 would give sufficient counter
play for Ramirez and he would indeed be
able to win his pawn back so I'm
thinking that that Armageddon what you
mentioned is looking more likely that's
right as pieces come off the board he
can't help but think this game might
turn out in to be a draw as well and
then we're going to be forcing the